أريد فقط أن أبدأ بهذا النوع من
الوقت الساحق للآباء ،
كيف تنصحهم بإبقاء أنفسهم
على الأرض أه لدعم
أطفالهم وعائلاتهم ، أعتقد أن الكثير من الآباء
يضعون الجميع
أمامهم بشكل واضح ويريدون
التأكد من أن أطفالهم  حسنًا ، لكن هذا
حقًا يمكن أن يحرق أحد الوالدين حقًا
أيضًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على استضافتي في
هذا الموضوع ، إنه موضوع بالغ الأهمية ،
لكنك تعلم أنني أعتقد
أن الواقعية مع توقعاتهم
وأن أعرف حقًا
ما هي قيمهم الحقيقية وأن تكون
أصليًا  مع أنفسهم أمر
بالغ الأهمية بالنسبة لهذا الأمر
، ومجرد معرفة أنهم ليسوا
وحدهم ، فهذا
وقت عالمي مليء بالتحديات
للآباء والأمهات
وهناك أماكن وأشخاص يمكنك التحدث معهم
للحصول على الدعم والشعور بوحدة أقل
ولمجرد
التغلب عليها
نعم ، أعني أن الأمر يبدو حقًا مثل
التواصل مع
من تكون قريبًا من الوالدين
والأشقاء والوالدين ، فأنت تعرف
والديك وأيًا كان نظام
الدعم هذا  يبدو أن وجودها في مكانها أمر
أساسي حقًا بدلاً من محاولة الاحتفاظ
بها بنفسك
تمامًا ، أعني أن أكبر شيء
تعلمته في الأبوة والأمومة هو كيف لا يمكنك
السكب من دلو فارغ ، كما تعلم
إذا كنت تكافح بنفسك ،
فسوف ينعكس ذلك  في كل مكان
خاصة لأطفالك
، فكيف يجب أن يفكر الناس في
هذا الأمر عندما يكونون مثل يا
إلهي ، لا أريد الآن
أن أتواصل مع شخص ما وأتحدث إلى شخص ما ولكن ما
مدى أهمية التواصل مع
الناس  فوق هذا
، إنه شريان الحياة الخاص بك وأنت تعلم أنني
أعتقد أن السعي للحصول على الدعم المناسب
مفيد للغاية وهذا
يبدو مختلفًا للجميع على نحو صحيح
يمكن أن تكون عائلتك التي يمكن أن تكون
دائرة أمك أو أعرف أن بعض أصدقائي
المقربين قد مروا بي
بعض أصعب أوقات الأبوة
ويمكن أن يكون الأقران جزءًا من سبب
تشكيلنا لنادي الأمهات جيدًا ، لقد كان
نادي الأمهات هو الآن نادي الآباء أو
ما تعرفه فقط للحصول على هذا النظير في المجتمع
الدعم والاحتفاظ بمساحة
للآباء لإجراء محادثات صعبة
عندما يحتاجون إلى ذلك